Diddy's character name I didn't know
Aaron was in one piece no he's not in
two columns over 700 character very
quiet when they were fighting Magellan
you know Tony just we are you need to
avoid shut up pace yourself Tony this is
my show you know when I talk people
listen welcome everyone to Red Cafe
number 25 25 weeks that we've been doing
this and the only person that's gotten
every week has been me I believe every
wonder why that is
everyone else can just leave whatever
they want they have their lives I should
meet here every week I don't do it cuz I
like it I do it because I have to know
of course I might enjoy doing this
sometimes welcome everyone in the chat
welcome to my people here by the way
this week we're gonna be discussing do
slice-of-life anime suck no gonna be an
interesting topic recon recon okay no
spoilers
um we'll see I don't know if we're gonna
rant or not but if we don't start
ranting because this is rank a favor I'm
gonna go off anyway on Tony for thinking
that sausage party is anything but a
flaming part pile of garbage
more [ __ ] flaming parm [ __ ] arm oh
that's just give me per [ __ ] reindeer by
going for that argument however first
let me introduce the people that here we
have Tony the black Kritika guy Tony
hello hello hello glad to be in the
presence of Briggs right back at you
that's it what I'm here doing that's all
I have to say I don't really care about
everyone else brilliant tell me why that
is why Tony Bryk Brin doesn't like you
then we have read from Brent's fandom
tapering hello hello you should make a
sprint cafe that's what Chad says so
make it make it so maybe future episodes
make it print a cafe will only make a
Bryn's cafe if you actually bring some
like cafe drinks coffee you know caramel
latte I've got some tea today
Oh
that doesn't count to eight also we have
in sprigs from all day ever may what up
Briggs hello hello good to be here what
is a slice-of-life I don't know it's a
thing that you find that one piece were
Luffy goes on an adventure of his home
life you got a slice of life like a
slice of tooth
Briggs if it doesn't feature characters
who cry all the time and then fight
people he doesn't know what it is so
this will be an eye-opening experience
for Briggs and we have all the time and
we have with us our bro anime recon aka
recon no pico how you have found out my
true form
I am recon no pico combined with havoc
no pico so now I am officially thus I am
recon the Sun of havoc so Krista
destroyed y'all go say who the hell is
Christopher Robin I just got it I know
this is once today
Rose Robin Oh Alec avek is over having
Christa Michael not can't wait for him
to return guys this is my god
it was not black bag in the shine let's
go house you're never gonna live that
down a little bit down now come on sorry
sorry about that
friends account has it Oprah no problem
Krista oh that's a clever name can I can
I just say for your friends that is a
clever name like well I'll let her know
it's it's like III slow clap when I
first heard Oh Mike well done it was
nailing me literally like 30 seconds to
figure it out
Oh Mac listen this this as out dawn
havoc no peak oh he's so happy he's so
hot like and happy you guys are gonna
forget havoc oh no you never forget
we never get oh oh my god you mean
crystal we're never forget gonna gonna
forget about Krista who joined I don't
know we're happy we have more in life
for you okay welcome Mackel not from
Mackel not glad to have you man glad to
have this new meme going on with the
Krista thing Christopher Robin Mackel
not Kristallnacht it's just it writes
itself how are you doing row I'm great I
just got home from work and I haven't
really had a chance to do anything else
I just kind of came into my basement and
sat down and turn my computer on but I'm
good
and especially since we're talking about
slice of life which is my my my not
expertise but I mean I watch it
sometimes you know but good good to be
here to be here I'm glad Toni I you know
what I'm glad Tony isn't insulting me
for once it's a nice change of pace I
could get used to it carry on let's
let's let's slice of life let's go buddy
I I mean I kind of did with the crystal
for Robin I had a valid excuse for that
some valid excuse are we looking what
you're looking for your honeypot that's
why no no I I do like me some honeypot
though it's good stuff yeah I heard
about all your adventures in the Hundred
Acre Woods what was it like having no
friends you you friends you know nothing
of my adventures in the Hundred Acre
Wood we don't speak of the Hundred Acre
Wood adventures oh I bet you would be
throwing in the seen asylum I mean I'm
having flashbacks right now this is too
much talk about talk about slice of life
talk about oh you know having one [ __ ]
arms gonna play some csgo do some aah oh
God
what could possibly go wrong and no so
he had his excuses Mac your excuses
would be nothing close except I've said
I'm totally fine with this I'm totally
like this yeah not only your trap phone
it hurts you deeply but it's okay told
you so the reason I wanted to get back
to Christopher Robin next time later on
for sure for sure
but uh the big thing that I want to talk
about this week is the whole content of
slice-of-life anime because you guys
know that there's people out there who
dislike this genre anime famously dot
anime snob and his crew they don't like
it they call them they call it slice of
nothing happens and they believe that
yeah they call it slice of nothing
happens anime because they think you
know there's nothing major going on it's
just wasting time it's just too much
cliche too many of the tropes same
troubles repeating themselves especially
in the high school setting so your high
school slice of life anime type of thing
so I thought that we would discuss this
now and see what you guys think about
slice of life anime in general about
some good ones about some bad ones how
to do it well how to fail and doing it
well and so on so who wants to start I
wanna know I come on store I just want
to say so basically what you're saying
is that that anime snob is a [ __ ]
idiot that doesn't understand the
definition of what John Woo is that what
you're saying yes no like what he just
described is slice of life in a nutshell
I mean that's life lots of nothingness
happens in life that's the point of a
slice of life it embodies that oh just
remember just remember there everyone's
allowed to be wrong at some no but
that's the thing goes if exception yes
some people can make the argument and I
personally have to spoiler alert I love
a lot of slice of life enemy but some
people will say listen I live my life I
don't give a [ __ ] about slice of life I
want to I want to see anime where stuff
happens I want to see anime where
actually it's actually you know
interesting to me not you know go
through the same [ __ ] I'm going through
my life but just watch something kept
the characters with colourful hair doing
the same type of [ __ ] so that's kind of
the argument there that's kind of my
standpoint a little bit not gonna laugh
I mean but you have like other genres
that will express and explore them the
slice of life genre is its own genre
that explores the mundaneness of life
but in a comical twist
well mostly comical sometimes they go
down the dramatic but usually that one
those are the ones that don't work for
me
the ones that are slice-of-life they go
down the comedic path those are the ones
that resonate the most uh but I'll give
it to our our leading expert on
slice-of-life Krista please tell us more
oh and by the way Briggs I'm glad that
you feel that way that you have some
skepticism about slice-of-life because
we need a balance for sure so if you
have frankly definitely we want to hear
what you think okay Mac let's go to you
first because you're anxious and [ __ ]
what yeah what's up mine is this where
say Who I am a Mac so wait you got
distracted by Brin let's all agree no
she was busy fluffing her hair again
that's it I was I was I was checking out
some great hair fluff edge and I just
got caught up in the laughing and I
heard what happened this is what you're
doing this what you going dick you're
going to China brah huh well I'm gonna
cuz on the topic of slice and let's
slice in life oh my god English on the
topic of slice of life and there we go
enunciate uh I mean I get it some people
don't like it cuz compared to you know
punching stuff explosions McGee anime
it's boring right but then again it
depends why are you watching anime if
you're watching anime for that reason
cool watch explosions or whatever but I
mean it's it's kind of like TV in the
sense that there's somebody for
everything right just cuz you like
action movies in real life doesn't mean
you're not going to enjoy like you know
just like a drama in real life or
something like that I like both I like
explosions
I like slice of life sometimes
explosions in my slice of life oh do you
mind Mac do you like telenovelas what do
I
I caught I got you I got you I got you
hey you're gonna have to like Spanish
soap operas cuz you said you like drama
so no I've watched a few I've been
watching a few K dramas recently like
really recently and they're great I did
I was like kind of against it I'd worded
but like a my roommate was watching them
and I was always like it doesn't look
like it's my thing but I actually sat
down for like five minutes of one who's
hilarious
I loved it that's besides the point
that's not slice of life that's slice of
Korean life talking about the animu I
mean like it like I was saying there's
there's something for everyone right
just because you you're into explosions
doesn't mean you can't enjoy something a
little more calm but I like slice of
life because it's it brings in that
setting of realness like this is for the
most part of anyway it's mostly grounded
so it kind of keeps you it it's kind of
a good reality check almost in some ways
depending on the show but and I think
it's interesting that you said you know
you can have action or like slice of
life and you can have anime that have
you know action and still be boring and
like my hero academia for example so
it's a very diverse well yeah see adamak
has a problem with letting go man
seriously we're done with that topic
well here is gone don't make me break
out the frozen on this stream I will I
will do it I swear yeah guys remember to
remember to drop the like if you agree
with me and also drop a like if you
disagree with me for Mac and the other
guys right so let's oka know you know
house not to like either way but they
did boku no hero have slice-of-life
yeah yes and hung up naga see there's so
much boku no hero
i mean um what this he got lost in his
own i'm like as soon as you martian or
water is like boca know you know slice
of life no no he was saying how like
there are some action shows that are
pretty boring like boku no hero academia
gotcha I gotcha Animax he always I know
wait deep voice says boku no hero more
like crisps ah no mustache the Christa
memes are starting oh [ __ ] his goals and
is in the chat I bet he's gonna be like
hey my hero academia is good guys
whatever would be like oh and you were
so mean to your own boss man by the way
ah Briggs so much
to play devil's advocate because I'm
gonna get later into which and uh slice
of life anime I really enjoy and stuff
like that because I some of them are
among my favorite anime
but I want to get Briggs to your point
about you know why you might not like
the genre or at least most of the genre
even if you like certain anime because
yeah it's not just even action here
sometimes you're like I want to watch a
show that puts me in dramatic situations
that you know that stuff that I won't
see every day and slice-of-life if it's
too many high school animes that you
watch them all and you're like yeah
maybe you like the first one but then
the second one third one it's like you
get all the same tropes repeat
themselves the same you know they're at
types you know you have your KU data you
here assume that it you have your harem
you have your dis you have your thought
and it gets old so yeah I wanna I wanna
Briggs get your opinion on this what are
some of your reservations about the
genre please feel free to speak really
so I've definitely opened up a lot more
to slice-of-life over the years but when
I first started I was completely against
it cuz like Mac said it brings in a lot
of the realness and what captured me for
anime was the unreal like unrealistic
setting like everything about it being
over-the-top and kind of unrealistic
that's what brought me into like anime
in general like Stroh like Full Metal
Alchemist one piece like he's like world
with magic and like all these
superpowers and stuff so I had a hard
time getting into something that was
real especially like high school setting
I still not crazy about high school
settings per se especially I was like I
got into anime before high school early
high school type of thing didn't like
high school
of course so I didn't want like it was
kind of an escape from that in a sense I
wanted something to be like take my mind
off it unrealistic just completely this
like super power stuff like that but
then there's some my favorite anime of
all time our slice of life and it kind
of overlaps as well for example the
devil is a part-timer fantasy the main
character the devil but
it's too like Tokyo and he just like a
part-timer having McRonald forever but
more like nothing happens I loved every
second of it second of it I think
they've had to take away from high
school and like I'll add a little bit of
like a fantasy aspect and you got me if
you take the fantasy world and put it in
the mundane world makes it much more
funnier and like another good example of
this is the opposite were Canosa be' is
basically the real world into a fantasy
world but with the mundane type of
setting in approach I think it it has to
be kind of original in that sense like
if we once you see the same high school
like setting over and over again it gets
a little bit boring and for me I just
didn't want that realness and butter
with it Luna says that highschool DxD is
her favorite slice of life so I'm
guessing that's a joke yes Oh have not
even used to that's not even close to a
slice of life how [ __ ] dare you make
fun of highschool DxD and my wife is
right that is like freaking Brynn fandom
level terrible you know video quoi
dare you bring that up again I'm just
going to shut this off here sorry
good grip don't worry we will do a black
Boris and NYPD Brinn roasting black a
critic on video it's gonna be yours it's
gonna be it's gonna is gonna end his
career the no the end his career he's
gonna start he's gonna start making
videos of a bronies and [ __ ] gone as
long as Mackel not exist my career will
always exist so uh I should try and move
the focus we're back we're back yeah but
okay wait but all seriousness now go
ahead play time because oh I was just
gonna agree with Briggs kind of in a
sense when I started watching anime I
was pretty much the same way but I think
that's because I hadn't found the right
type of slice of anime slice of life
anime sliced salami yep
get that slice no but like I just hadn't
found the right show for me that I
I found like a good balance of both like
we kind of said like there are good
things slice-of-life like comedy I think
is really great that's what I was
looking for the shows I think that I
watched were more like drama
slice-of-life or like how am I gonna
solve this problem it's like I don't
really care this is like real-life
problems like not that exciting to me
but the comedy ones I enjoy so I had to
find the right ones but I did not like
slice-of-life in the beginning like I
was much more towards the exciting
fantasy if you could've gave me two
options I would have always picked the
fantasy in the action over the slice of
life and or con give me that URI oh nice
baby my soul maka by the way talking
about Brent's shotgun and soul let me
know if you're down for next week for
not naruto vs 1 peace ran cafe showdown
because Lotus's game minute break this
game and the same place wins how's that
even a competition well it's gonna be I
mean I live in the showdown on Red Cafe
Bros so you know I'll have to tune in
for that but I mean that's gonna be a
slaughter fest of one piece proportions
I don't care about either I unwatched
Matt much from either gonna be like a
good moderator it's like I don't care
level you NAB it are you I'm gonna watch
one piece wins 11 times out of 10 I
don't know
come on load times breaks but I want to
know Briggs is why did you not like high
school did you get bullied for being a
muscular jock by all the Nerds nicely
how dare you like Adam a shock
you can all do cool um I wouldn't say I
hate hated high school like it was fun
fun experience but uh it's not like you
spend all day in high school I don't
want to come home and watch anime about
high school you know you wanted to get
away from that I want to see some Super
Saiyan 3 year for badasses beauty
feather up you know who yeah Briggs just
flex just flex to show people what a
nerd you are I'm good I didn't have
enough I got my mouth closed hombre
might break the camera I mean it's just
it's a go
look one-handed push-ups in class oh no
I'm just playing Briggs we all know
you're a Super Saiyan love you that love
you too bro love you too
whoa whoa I didn't ask for your your
nice on the show please yep yeah Anitha
we called this enrollment we don't take
everything you know don't just let it be
the letter B Tony they were they were
born to make history together November
no don't you say oh I was that was a
fresh one Mac that was a fresh joke are
you gonna say that that ah I am the
weakest link goodbye next in some in
terms of some much you know timely
timely jokes I was I was gonna say it's
time to did it at the delivery tool but
I mean that when did your [ __ ]
copying yogi you by any chance what you
Peter you you you you are you I mean
yogi oh sorry yogi okata pronouncing
your you is it yogi oh is it Yugi you
how does it look and say it sounds like
a for kids like extras everybody and
Harvick words hmm come play some more
Yukio with me a monk a yogi okay okay
guys okay
Howard mispronounced it uh I mean [ __ ]
[ __ ] ensues right now look into his
enema
that wasn't even acceptable man recon
recon or mispronounced you yo it's okay
we're gonna move on okay everyone I Col
comment by dark night thinking easy bash
to the discord she says that she thinks
that the reason high school is such a
comment said thing is that have their
best memories in high school right so
then even adults who are older than the
high school age like these anyway
because it's like they're reliving you
know an interesting part of their
childhood which i think is interesting
point because like yeah high school
enemy or not just washed by high school
kids and the reason i school is so
popular is because even older people who
watch it want to relive those days kind
of thing right i think um
I think it was DG bro did you bro made
an excellent video explaining why there
was so many high school anime because in
Japan like once you graduate from high
school you like this like you have to
have your life find out you know you
gotta know what college you're going to
what your career will be all that stuff
in high schools like that one period of
time where you have a lot of freedom a
lot of time you explore who you are you
have a lot of those memories kind of
like what you already said on a Mac and
that's why there's such a huge focus on
high school anime now for me personally
I didn't really have that terrible time
in high school if I would say I loved
high school I liked high school anime
because it was a reflection of one my
experience to a certain degree but with
the hilarious spin to it and I love that
[ __ ] now when they went overly dramatic
that's when I was just like oh you're
getting a bit too much that's why I was
so hard to get into Clannad it was just
so over the top of its drama great anime
I'm just like who cares man kid you guys
make it seem like the world is ending
for some reason it's the same problem I
have what shuffle and [ __ ] in air and
all those other really overly dramatic
high school anime I might get over
yourselves iru how many one are you
[ __ ] kidding high final I don't care
shorten sorry this a joke Tony epochal
not well to be fair the first season of
clannad's I don't know what I like
Clannad as a whole problems with it it's
not the greatest anime you know it
everyone likes to suck that and animates
dick and I was brutally honest about how
I felt when I reviewed it first of all
that anime hasn't been out there you
look at all second of all you soon clean
as gender Tony yeah yes somehow it's
just non-offending cloud is a beautiful
woman okay in my mind so you shut up
Tony you shut your damn mouth but but in
terms of canal yeah the first season is
much more just your slicing like
highschool anime whereas after story is
really cool because it goes beyond that
into the adult world as we were saying
Tony where you do have responsibilities
and it switches the
game up which I like because even though
the first one is not as good it's like
the fact that they go beyond that they
don't do just another year in high
school in the new season they actually
go beyond that I thought was very cool
and kind of trend setting but in terms
of the world ending these the other
world really is ending Tony did you not
pay attention Oh implication world with
the robot like yeah I know I know but
what hasn't know what to let this world
whatever happened in that world but in
but it was like for me I'm serious that
you are not and that's why cannot to me
his favorite ending of all time in anime
so internet ending credits and everybody
in distress
look look Mac was so offended he just
had to leave he was like I can't deal
comments and just came over space out
friends like you can't with Mac you
mention Clannad there's a tear just
coming up down his eye you can't do it
he means he needs time to cry oh boy not
trying to be mean on Clannad but I don't
believe that the you are really praised
I feel like that sure other anime that
does like I feel like there are other
anime that does the exact same thing
that Clannad did but even better you
know fine example of this in my opinion
was um on Ohana which tackled that
over-the-top melodramatic high school
tendency but the focus was really on
high school it was about the friends and
the relationships that were that they
had prior to the death of one of their
friends that is well executed drama with
a very fulfilling ending where Skynet is
up I'm going to stop you there Tony but
do you have a [ __ ] soul give a heart
letters would you lot would you marry I
hate one piece that should count for
something
I have any if anyone hate they have a
soul
the thing is did you not freaking have
feelings at the very end of Clan and
like the second scene indeed not have
feelings of the death of poor Naga did
you not cry because I
Dhin Dhin cried if they do to him
because I would have tried it right they
would have privatizing me because while
you were talking about God on earth
while you were talking about you then
I'm right now I feel like he you cried
towards them who they or do they not
renege on her death yes they do
okay wrote and what I don't want to talk
about this getting concern about that if
you go strikes my this is the greatest
ending ever
okay I don't want to get into this I
don't wanna know no we can do it because
I'm gonna be explaining why system
greatest ending ever
in a special video yeah and after that
it's gonna solve it once or all you'll
be done you're gonna say to me Anna Mac
I respect you and I love you and I agree
with you thanks to this video
Thank You Man thank you for making my
life better and I'm gonna say you're
welcome to me but your that is to come
that is to come
I agree with you though for AnoHana also
a great anime that I thoroughly enjoyed
but one thing that we brought up earlier
and I think is an interesting thing to
consider is that a lot of these guys
okay so okay the last thing I heard was
that I had to go cry just did not true
no but at this point at this point I
just hear that you know OST of Kanade
and I just like the I just start crying
like I don't even see the scene anymore
it's like oh god I remember iron but
anyway interesting he was brought up is
the fact that a lot of slice-of-life
anime actually incorporate supernatural
elements so like fantasy slight flick
slice of life paranormal slice of life
that was a part-timer
Haruhi Suzumiya Kanade err Kanaan um how
do you feel yeah yeah that's a list
threw me off
I never heard it pronounced that way
yeah it's hot okay Steph Lumia it's not
Rui suzumiya haruhi does anyone say
nobody here say that are you yeah yeah
so the point is the point is what do you
guys like oh there are other ones like
Toradora or as some of you say Toradora
so I don't throw you all
Nonna Toradora this alone doesn't
include supernatural element so that's a
slice of life that does not an example
of a popular one of course and and so on
but what do you think about this old
genre-bending stuff with slice of life a
lot of them having supernatural elements
do you like it do you not like it I
personally love it because I couldn't
get into the whole with like a normal
social life thing
after first anyway I like it when like
when there's an anime it has like a
slice of life and other genres are well
if it's just slice of life alone then I
wouldn't really be that much of an
entertaining show at least in my opinion
interesting Tony or maybe it would
depend like cuz I do like the
gender-bending like you know Briggs and
havoc over there um I like when they Ben
didn't like a glow coming to it there
were actually others sliced up my life
animate that are purely sight slice of
life uh I have three examples uh she can
drop the first half of ocg drop and uh
miss enlightening all three are just
straight-up [ __ ] ice of life anime yes
and they're very effective at what they
do
capturing um a slice of the life of
these and with the latter two it's the
father raising a daughter which for some
reason I just seem to love legit didn't
just love it I agree with you Tony I
actually I'm with you I enjoyed who's
looking awful odd as well you know
what's another good one
Oh Fitz on the slope attending them I
think well it's not you guys unless you
know Tom man thank you oh yeah I thought
I was it's interesting and it's also a
period kind of drama right it takes
place in the sixties I believe so it's
interesting in the sense when it's a
period drama and a slice of life and I
enjoyed it anything not as so much but
still overall I enjoyed it and it was
pretty sad
it was pretty blasé I would say the
wouldn't you agree that that fits in the
tone of a size of life as life is kind
of like the like how life kind of just
ends is kind of blase it's not as epic
as you want it to be and ending on a
pretty neat blase noting is kind of in
tune with what it was trying to go for
yeah reunite after all those years is
very nice that's fish yeah like when you
were out sweetness and lightening sorry
I'll finish my thought
trick what I was gonna say bread so good
okay thank you thank you automatic for
turning the time over to myself why not
when you talk about people lining it did
it did remind me of how I did I really
liked it and I remember thinking like
this is so like not Dells not the word
but it's so mundane like him raising his
daughter like the struggles that come
with it like why am I so invested and
think this is enjoyable to watch but
that's exactly it it doesn't have to be
like these big incredible moments it's
just like slowly growing it's a slow
burn slice-of-life anime is just like a
slow burn kind of show you just watch it
for what it is there's no necessarily
like huge incredible big moments but
it's just the journey that you go on
another one that I really liked um was
language and that's the thing it was so
slow and yet I'm like I'm enjoying this
I'm having fun with this but it's not
the most exciting thing so what am I
talking about
I don't like what's flying which I've
never heard of it it was a two seasons
ago she's a girl who's just like
training to be a witch so she kind of
leaves and she gets all these like
supernatural kind of friends that come
and they just you know live life
together but supposing it sounds
charming is that sounds very charming
mm-hmm but I just member thinking why
why do I like this so much it's just so
mundane and everyday but that's what's
enjoyable about it is that it doesn't
have to be these huge moments it's just
like the journey and like these cute
little characters doing their little
things that's really all you don't need
you don't need like a group of [ __ ]
more
on a shitty boat one that can stretch so
long another that carries a puny [ __ ]
are they mean what their doctors already
I thought reindeers flew and hang out
with Santa Claus or something we don't
mean to show that's different and mate
I'm like the vise we need a library like
convey also good can we honor this
wondering can we all agree on one thing
though that as much as I see life is its
own genre I think every anime to ASA
earn degree incorporates in its
storytelling it might not be a huge
presence but it's a small presence I
know like with every Shonen anime there
is always a bit of slice of life where
they tackle real issues or they'll have
them really small intimate moments that
feel very slice of life is that when you
watch one piece Briggs but there were
some episodes where I mean they
literally just stay in a town a group
and I'm like that's pretty that's nice
little calming moment yeah like I just
like thing and like kind of figure out
what's going on and stuff like that
there's a lot of it's a very slow-paced
trail for sure because they try to not
catch up to the sort of source material
so there's a lot of episode where just
like just on a boat and like haha well
havoc the he's gone what that's on our
EP uyp call me bud what um where's the
piece Christopher wood welcome to the NH
team here that's what I was thinking of
I I think it counts for sure wait
wouldn't I'll welcome to the nhj I'd say
so it's like I haven't finished it but
it's from what I've gathered from it
it's a little like slice of life you
supernaturally sort of shut in life yeah
I'm lagging I'm lagging so bad
hahaha I think yeah I couldn't hear it
on the part-timer a Tejada would be my
top 3 for me yeah I know Hannah is one
of the ones were like I can't really
listen to the soundtrack without just
like all of the fields coming off so
Mike ooh okay
like there's enough listen to something
else oh look it's bad and a baby hello
kids
what's the speak how do i word mmm-hmm
by the way Gilgamesh and the chat is sad
that no one noticed and that's that's
unmanned I feel your pain
I know Russell Morris I ran an ad or
tyrannical who I saw in your letter open
extreme your BCG male BCG wants you to
address real life once you tell more
real life oh that's a great big one
that's a great one
thank you on that it's twice life really
good by the way am i lagging a bit okay
BRB alright that and was it ever coming
out all right trying pro can I talk
about my slow slice of life go ahead so
for me I did not I personally did not
really enjoy high school because the
truth is I don't how to say this but um
I got bullied for a little bit of you
know being an anime otaku person was it
was until legend to own a body pillow
was that why no that's not live I just I
don't know why I just got bullied but in
other words but when I come back home
sit down on the chair and I watch anime
i watch like another school
slice-of-life anime and it just breaks
me from the reality world and just i
just immerse myself into watching this
slice of life school anime i mean for me
slice of life is like it's more
character-driven than the story driven
let's say for example one of my personal
favorite slice of life anime is a say
candle how to raise a boring girlfriend
that series really is it's super good
it's really good it's about a bunch of
these care
to create a video game I mean the story
is pretty and it's pretty general just
watch characters create creating a video
game together they spend time together
but what what made it good is about how
the character is all together they work
together they develop together and then
they succeed this is what for me makes a
slice-of-life
really good but if it's just slice of
life alone and it doesn't really have
any other genres it just doesn't really
appeal to me let's say like another
slice of life that's really good is like
yokai yokai no kanata that is a slice of
life but it has a little bit of school
in it but there's just things that do
not happen in real life in reality so
that's what I really like about it that
other genres also like mob psycho
there's a slice-of-life anime it has
lots of action the animation is weird
and all but it was still so much fun to
watch because it was funny uh yeah
that's it mostly for me but I do watch a
lot of slice and life's in my own time
recon is a really good point actually
about slice lima bean character-oriented
because a lot of people will be like oh
annoy I want a more exciting plot I want
it to be more you know I have a lot of
philosophical things maybe or something
like saying deeper things where as a
character study is still a legitimate
thing right and you know that um if you
look at things like you know literary
fiction for example a lot of it is not
plug driven but character driven so that
is I think a really good point and the
other thing about bullying that's also
very deep topic and I think maybe in the
future we should do I ran a fááá about
bullying and people being bullied about
regarding anime because as Luna
mentioned in the chat and she talked
about it's in the discord before she
gets bullied right now for watching
anime like in her high school there's
issues with people bullying her and
stuff so I think that maybe we should
try to tackle such a serious topic on
Ren cafe in the coming weeks what do you
guys think that's actually a really good
idea I agree with them I found like a
good idea then that sounds like a I got
makkal not
Christa is Christa gonna be joining us
for next run cafe what maybe I'll ask
her maybe the guys will definitely look
into for next week Sol is saying in the
chat he doesn't like Naruto that much he
just wants to rag on one piece
well Sol if you think that Naruto is
better than one piece then you have to
make the argument that Naruto is better
one piece if you wanna rag on one piece
that's fine but we want to have it a
showdown where they can also you know
bricks can also defend himself by
ragging on anime you prefer to 1p we
can't just have you all let's talk about
what he sucks and they have a defender
so they have to be able to go on the
attack as well so marker
well if loaded defend art oh right
I mean one of these not spooks glad what
this does suck so I mean what more words
you don't need to make an argument for
that okay yeah what'd you say that's
what you claimed but I think Briggs are
2spooky are gonna kick some ass and I
think creep Ellen might be there to give
them a hand well so oh by the way Tony
I've been meaning to ask you this book
is that your wedding outfit no that was
actually a suit I wore for a play I was
in when I was in high school
ironically you know or good really do
not look like a high school guy to me in
that picture
no trust me if you look like a genuine
mature person who goes out and has a job
buddy
you my deal I was 13 years old
also my friends at their house and more
girl I'll call them and they're now more
fun
pick up the phone is like hello and I'm
like yo solo is a system he's like who's
this like who watch a daughter and I
swear to God the moment they pick up the
phone is like hello hey it's me Taylor
it's Tony he's like my dad Dutch like
some 20-year 22 year old man just creepy
Anton I'm like I'm five years old
sitting here and some adult thinks I
sound like a 20 year old I was so
crushed kid just want to live your
childhood I guess that's why I like
slice of life so much because they let
they let me live vicariously through
them school by the way Tony I appreciate
that you corrected when you were gonna
say ironic but then you said
coincidental thank you yes the word
ironically used poorly in the lexicon of
the world
yeah me and Bo then goes in and I hate
when people misuse the word ironic yeah
cuz it's hot ironic it's just
coincidental yeah I met on like CNN and
[ __ ] they misuse it all the time like oh
god I mean what did you expect from fake
news it's just good I say the doesn't
help you have reported you know CNN
reports seven of these since season 7 is
coming out I'm just saying way into the
future
I think season season 7 is like probably
in that rate when you're never but in my
and money and why you forget I'm just
make my calculations my math
calculations by the way I suck ass at
maths uh math absolutely maths maths
that's what we're all in the UK like
means I can even call it maths here
where you're a squat to be honest I'm
really getting into the habit of
speaking as an English gentleman haha
like when you live in a certain country
you just catch the accent so fast when
you like you used to it and like all
your friends are British I'm like okay
then you start you know getting the
accent so just get some chips and all
like some fish and chips young man next
thing you know you're a part of the
Kingston have you guys tried fish and
chips I grew up on fish and chips oh
wait I was born in fish and chips
Boldin yeah I know what's going on in
the job and I get messages like what
Amos what he said the lineaments
messaging man I was going what now
because because they say you look older
than me I'm doing what now I'm kidding
I'm playing dude I'm playing but yeah
okay okay what else should we talk about
win terms of this slice of life stuff
well we kind of talked about some of the
good ones
why don't we talk about the ones that
kind of turn us off the slice of life
like ones that we couldn't stand or we
don't get the clarity of them okay great
point and why don't you and give us some
you and by the way just say something
about real life because your boy over
there tyrannical good example of how did
you ice life while also ready um you
sound like a [ __ ] robot but the audio
is so bad no I'm using my phone that's
why I'm lagging on a computer so I think
it might be a connection or something
that if it's both devices fortunately
because I always like hearing your
inside using I'm using my 4G at this
moment so it's actually only smoothly
much more smoothly but I apologize havoc
so I'll try to get my mic soon but this
fellow realize a quick example of how to
do nice life incorporating a bit of or
the talk comedy the super super NASM
come it's a serious topic let me know
handle correctly read it read it and it
makes it seem very melodramatic yourself
use drama pieces in the real life for me
and realistic normal as a high schooler
in as an adult especially like I don't
think come on maker because me know
I have to say that my life suck right
now and feeling sluggish we know your
purpose my eyes go in yet I'm in a
monster you know you're crying for you
all right Tony um I love your ideas at
some points I did not understand you but
at some points I did but I still respect
that well III think I caught most of
what you said Tony and that's a fair
point I haven't seen real life myself
but so every sounds pretty good
and I got your point about the melodrama
and how some slice of life anime think
the melodrama too far and it feels kind
of jarring and by the way in the chat we
got like [ __ ] trending like cyborg
Tony Tony Darth Vader Oh poop cyborg
Tony the Tony can you say I am your
father
I just did didn't we didn't hear same
thing again okay okay well my friends
say say it for me then I I put her on
the spot guys yeah you did I was trying
to look up slice-of-life anime okay Oh
to answer your question the Lanham Act
about ones that we don't like I think
the one I hated most it was my foot half
it was my introduction to slice of life
I [ __ ] hated um oh god I forgot its
name already um it's a one about the
little cute girls I one of them has blue
hair um oh lucky star can hate it lucky
smart so far the first I was all like
it's basically these these little girls
are talking about their their bento
boxes and the food in bento boxes ah no
is happening right now
episode 2 I was like ah I'm coming too I
can't I cannot push any further right
now I'm different you that's a slice of
I've done poorly because it's so
correction 'less and it lacks it likes a
sort of charm you know just like hey hi
this lunch I have this lunch - and you
that annoying ass music in the backdrop
like burro don't know
yeah I actually I'm not I have to think
about which slice life Anna might didn't
like although I didn't like that one you
know that one where like they hang out
on the roof of the high school like
that's like that's not enough
information upper every time critical
short well have to I'll have to think
about I'll have to think about which
ones I did like but I want to I know me
Mac if you had and you didn't like in
particular and then we'll go to breaks I
don't even know man
uh I'm just trying to think of all this
less of life I've watched there's gotta
be one I didn't like uh I wasn't a big
fan of that newer key Studios one I
don't know if that's slice of life now
it's not even slice of life uh go to
briggs I'll keep on thinking I don't
know if I have any that I disliked own
uh not because they don't exist I'm sure
there's lots of slice of life that's bad
I guarantee there's lots of slice
applies this bed but uh I can't think of
ones that I've watched that I haven't
enjoyed yet so take it away Briggs will
I do some brainstorming um well I
dropped lucky star after one episode
like Tony
I dropped Clannad after two episodes
unfortunately you suck but I'm okay to
be fair that's one of the first length
of that life anime I've ever watched and
I've at that time it just wasn't what I
wanted
I'm gonna go back now it would be I'm
gonna tell goals and all you on you man
he's gonna be so disappointed
FSO Chu is like what his favorite
episodes really yeah I don't know why
blow a smoke man
that rains
at the basketball it [ __ ] you love that
so yeah man well I told you about the
older um let's think
oh wait Morris someone was asking the
chat like 30 times
oh my god already forgot like my
teammate romantic comedy what do you
guys think about that
oh that's a good ass anime my go-to
comedy yes it's so good to see zijn I
really liked it
ah the anime do try to have my back cuz
I was saying in the chat that I have no
idea what's going on a slice of life and
no conversation
my worst slice of life that I've seen is
a girl that where is I forgot what the
titles but it's that blue haired little
girl that wears like an eye patch on her
eye and she has a power so she releases
it or what is it called it's love tuna
Bo and other delusions yeah that one I I
didn't like it in my opinion wasn't
appealing I just was like what I thought
was kind of funny it's it's funny and
charming and the fact that it's ripping
off toradora basically exactly that's
yeah exactly that's why I didn't like it
it's just like uh I was like ok toreador
was so much more better than this but
it's like almost like a copy I still I
was like let it like it at all
she'll even ends it ends like toward or
to reach me not always I'm always
thinking that it's just a copy of
toradora but it's like it's so bad
recon are you saying Toradora like art
fun uh I'm sorry sorry good Dora Dora
sorry not Dora right you know what a
poor look I can't help it okay sometimes
gonna be I'm just Kendall you have to be
a weeb I don't even care if you're not
only okay okay I'm a snob you [ __ ]
look
and sometimes the pronounce English and
sometimes I pronounce Japanese but
mostly I do both so if you unless you
all the toradora okay why do I have
wonder with durarara if you guys know
about it raaaah it's heavily it
subtly like super natural obviously but
it's kind of a slice of life as well one
thing I didn't like about that show is
the pacing overall it's not a horrible
one but what I didn't like the pacing I
thought I loved the characters I thought
there was some really interesting
characters however I thought that they
were focusing on the wrong characters
like the main guy what was his name the
leader of the Chris mooring yeah yeah
ah I didn't think he was not interesting
like even though I thought like you know
the bartender guy was really interesting
and other characters yeah yes so I
thought like it was a great premise
great characters but I didn't quite like
the pacing and where it went so that was
a bit of a disappointed with me but one
thing I do want to mention is like uh um
Miyazaki Ghibli films like from up on
poppy Hill and the wind rises are great
slice-of-life
films so let's my films as well can be
really good if it's about the
storyteller can the story top bring the
mundane situation to life in a very
enthralling way Miyazaki has that magic
touch man I mean he can't go wrong with
the man yeah yeah I tried to get my
friend Raj Babu a meal um except you
know Porco Rosso kind of sucks right
breath I actually like that I like pork
roast like what Rosa dude I tried to get
my friend to watch Kiki's Delivery
Service and she said she's like this is
too boring I was like but but it's about
she's so cute and like but I could she
probably felt the same way about sliced
life that's just like there's nothing
happening like yes but know what I will
say the raccoon one went on for a bit
too long there were that was loose my
boys um I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have
to go I got some stuff to do
Oh on the cuber thank you for joining us
and have a good night good now take it
easy man Lextran cafe up I'm going to
talk about bullying next rank of a is
probably going to be the naruto vs 1
peach showdown okay but we'll be in
touch about that
okay expect havoc no peak havoc to be in
the next run cafe we will see with um
yes right away
I think we'll be in the next Briggs
anyways Briggs let's good luck man you
haven't said anything a while
yeah Briggs about so I don't know just
are you sure Oh got nothing to say
honto are fake prices still horrible
yeah they're ridiculous can't afford
anything you know that's great because
we're about to be in your city
real soon whoo I don't know it we get to
be real poor after hmm yeah guys
nanomite North 25th to 20 so say when is
that 26 to 28
Oh May so yeah we'll be meeting up there
Briggs Mac me goes in vector Maximus
it's gonna be freakin insane guys insane
stuff we're gonna have I got a panel
actually approved for a panel about
anime and philosophy they're going to be
hosting it's going to be on the Sunday
at noon but I'm also holding on to
hopefully get a code geass panel
approved that one I think is still under
review so we'll keep you post on that as
well yeah it's gonna be nuts I love it
that's all excited pants dude
go ahead man are you guys all gonna come
from the panel don't anime philosophy
cuz I'm afraid no one's gonna show up so
Briggs Mac I'll be the signs there be
whoo girls Tony with us it up and we
will woo wee woo it's like so talking
about Plato's allegory of the cave
well I got good for ya wait I never got
to hear a bomb Mackinaw door Bryn's
least favorite slice of life because I
was dealing with my with my my least
favourite slice of life was Star Trek
The Next Generation it sucked
worst slice of life at
what my aunt she was pretty bad but I'm
Lola Lola you never actually gave us an
answer no honestly I couldn't I couldn't
really think of one
like I've I'm sure their shows out there
that I've started watching it's like a
but I mean I've never been like super
active into seeking out like slice of
life to watch I wasn't a big fan of what
was a yarmulkes first time I couldn't
stay into it
I couldn't don't here get me started on
that enemy right now I couldn't well as
long as we agree that's good
so I guess I guess that would be the one
I'd have to go with that and girls is
girls Bravo's and slice-of-life is it
not it that's just a cheap
that's just smut most all the one that's
Annabelle yeah that's a lot that I
finished the whole series
oh yeah that's i probably i probe after
link then what about you Bryn I didn't
get to hear yours
well that's the thing like I think the
most recent one that I had started
watching and then didn't end up watching
was actually this season it was love
rice yep I tried to watch it guys tried
to watch it I was like I just did not
feel in this this is not exciting
you should guys should look up yes and
opposites of it about these boys who
love rice holy shite
what a compelling story I made I to like
the release so I can relate nice to Mike
Rice I know it was like I wanted to like
it cuz I was like oh it's based off um
like a game and like oh my gosh the puns
are so bad alright so like I should work
I love puns totally knows like oh
they're so great Tony we could make an
anime about you and it could be called
Tony on rice I'm not frozen dude I'm so
excited it's like yeah I might have to
watch by the way it's pretty cut if
you're gonna be a
I mean north let me know I'm wondering
if anyone who actually watches the
channels are going to be at anime North
cuz I don't know how many of you guys
are in Canada or anywhere near this ah
Stephanie Canada sucks
I think oh yeah hey yeah hey at least
here it's not uh f ed the trucks that
humidity and we don't have mosquitoes
that we have to punch rather than flick
away so Tony I hope you don't get
attacked by an alligator bud
oh it's just me alligators are very
docile compared to their aggressive
cousins so I'll be fine
I gotcha
dr. bro let me see that all right uh
sighs wife kids on the slope or is that
a slice of life I think count it
yeah it's not there it's about jazz what
would what more could you want
so I guess in that sense if there's a
musical anime Nodame cantabile is also a
slice of life upon music school and
stuff and I enjoy that Anna I gotta look
at the title but there was a music anime
I don't know if it it's a slice of life
but I watched part of it and I was like
I'm just not invested pearls tuna in a
waddle like group he had a magical
instrument a magic wood oh I got I left
once there was magic involved was like
oh I see
over the kazoo cuz kazoos are pretty
magical
oh no it's violent oh look
luck or dad or dough well maybe someone
knows that but I watched part of it I
don't know if that's considered slice of
life it was definitely more high school
but I watched it and I was like Oh
magical flute or like magical violin no
I thought not seal in it magical
wildlands I never heard of it
sounds interesting violins and slice of
life reminds me if you're aligned hey it
is it's great to be in life it's good
it's a sad slice of life it hurt my soul
Barney yes
yeah because in the second - laughs no
even in the last episode like before the
break they referenced Gurren Lagann by
saying some like do the impossible some
[ __ ] and I'm like okay okay morning at
that and then it's like they purposely
wanted to slap me in the face yeah give
you give you dangle some hope in front
of your face and just like no no not
happening
yeah [ __ ] that that was that was such
that was not true
that was not cool yeah I guess the
ending just you're like a poor which
disappointed me damn it really what that
[ __ ] cliche I know I only Tony can
guess it then you know it it's not gonna
work I know it's still effective show I
still like just that there were some
parts I wasn't a fan of I did not like
the inclusion of that little girl who
felt kind of like Patti empty third hey
we need another love interest for a guy
I scored this little girl that's like I
like assume today emo was like crazy we
had the best friend
we had the pretty blond Japanese these
people just love blondes for some kiss
me and you know we had that one girl was
a piece that was his rival which I
thought she was more interesting than
any of the arms she should have in the
main room yeah that she was cool she was
cooler like her but yeah the thing is
that's the one thing that might put
these slice-of-life anime they do get
into a bit of trouble like that because
it's almost they have to have a
checklist so it's like you've got your
tune that it you got your cooter you got
your goofy best friend you got your you
know this your that so a goofy grin yeah
so in that sense it's like that's where
I think criticism comes from it's like
they just like have a box that I need to
check off all these everything rather
than going a more creative route but you
could say that for any jar of anime I
mean we've seen very generic action
anime I mean you'll say boku no hero
academia is false all that Catholics so
generic it's the middle so amazingly
generic guys so let's do it I know I say
I say
Erica Briggs is like yes I love it like
he thought the remote is a bad thing is
like [ __ ] I like that stuff
my I like I do so I'm a generic
annotation me I need that [ __ ] you're
also my point the point I'm getting
asked to say that a lot of people hate
slice alive because if those two little
box is is right but also is it a fair
argument because that could be any anime
any other make you fall into a box of
cliches when you're specifically geared
towards that genre I personally thought
that deadly like the seven deadly sins
as much as it's entertaining
falls into the trap of a lot of shown in
action anime it's fanservice which was
just over abundant and pointless you
know and it would focus so much on that
when there are interesting characters
that need development still I'm like god
damn it stop that
oh by the way by the character is being
interesting like the entire show for me
yeah you know but I mean a lot of anime
fault traps and cliches and stuff like
that I think comedy and slice of life
fall into more traps and most anime
because they do they are very repetitive
for a similar function so yeah um on
suta talk and I said something
interesting he said that mushishi
quino's journey and mucho ten Kazoku are
all irregular slice of life I guess I
would agree with mushishi that it's an
irregular slice of life in the sense
that it's a paranormal slice of life but
still slices of life in ginko Kinko's
life
however for quino's journey i would say
that's not a slice of life hammock that
is more of an adventure and I may
request anime in my opinion and I
haven't seen which attempt Kazoku so I
can't speak Tony laughs Tusker that's no
one just loves us today everyone I just
dropped out salsa band on yeah that's
our enemy knows no one loves loves it
oh maybe that's our drama worst anime
ever geez these are biggest life
problems here in the slice of life anime
we have no friends
it and then just do that it is Red Cafe
a slice-of-life anime that is a good
question
ooh deep well I one of the best ones
it's true I mean it should get all the
awards you know when we do Red Cafe
awards nothing clearly top of the list
all of them we'll see though because at
Anime North the slice off enemy is gonna
reach you know some action-adventure
[ __ ]
it's going to be interesting we're gonna
be meeting up we're gonna be potentially
you know going fist to fist facing off
and battles and [ __ ] so it's gonna be
interesting
okay I'm always shocked when I see
people have legs like what the heck is
like you yeah those two what what oh
that's how I feel whenever I see you
tours like standing I'm like whoa you're
not just like this in existence I don't
get it oh yeah reg Rafi is a weird weird
slice of life like Tony are you back
with us
I'm back uh how do I sound solid so far
so good
Oh God von boo said that red cafe's a
shoujo my bid is yes let's all transform
that woo I can only guess that's the
magical girl show we can transform still
we can still transform laughs yeah dude
hmm my transformation is the exact same
is what I'm wearing though so like whoa
look at she's all these sparkles exactly
the same outfit whoo incredible this
magical girl ever mm-hmm
you're always you're always so so right
Krista I know I know it's even that's so
Krista and I women soo in yeah that's
why I always say this is a shoujo cuz we
got Brinn we got Krista oh yeah mm I
guess I can't let people sign and on my
computer ever again because I cannot get
rid of the Christopher Robin come on
please it's a great name I'm I'm
choosing finally please tell me her last
name is Robin day
Oh gravy amazing great oh man by Mac
you're a public personality you gotta be
careful man everything you do and say
will be used against you by the rest of
us yeah that's that's that's why I just
overtone everything with like that's the
curse of being a pulpit we just makes it
by the way Tony can you tell us why your
name is Tony carbon because we know
that's not your last name so what's the
deal with that well when I was creating
my Google my Google Gmail I wanted to
use something that wasn't my typical
last name I was like a my middle name is
carbon well I just call myself Tony
carbon for my email that'd be cool you
know a lot of people use their middle
name as their last name for emails or a
facebook name and stuff like that so I
just have to do the same thing with my
email and I think are bizarre cool is a
cool name some proper now its carbon its
carbon but so cool cool if you like your
middle name to be part of the periodic
table of elements that Wow ever that
Womble you know oh right
or your name could be Brent I literally
hi
my middle name is ty legs is your middle
name Akili impiety tracks is it actually
it is
hello get out the British is good that's
a lot of it
that's awesome walk that's so crazy
your parents must really they had a
sense of humor they're like wait a
minute what if Brooke honey man that
discussion right there was a you boom
boom no one gets that joke besides me no
I think I'll get it we're we're getting
it you Briggs school [ __ ] II got it oh
yeah
droll I'm hot for you what's up yeah
played bricks you caught me with my
pants down quite literally that's why
he's not throwing himself yeah
well I don't want my damn phone to
explode in my hand yeah of course you
know you know that you're a public
figure so when you don't have your pants
on during a stream you don't just show
up live like Mac would you want to know
something funny there are some streams
where I show or I actually do it with no
pants some no I know some is right now I
mean pump those numbers Tony can't be
some it's gotta be all do you think I'm
wearing pants right now
oh why I would assume so why would I
wear panties yep do you think Michael at
merge clothes he never wears clothes
means naked all the time he's a step
above us all holy street naked because
it's like a thing and it's like a tick
and that's why I can't show it drugs
well let's not talk about Mike okay he
broke my heart
he left me out to dry and uh I know so
let's never talk on him again maximum
dramatic life is life and on that the
dramatic slice of life note I think we
can start wrapping this baby up thanks
everyone in the child who came and
contributed to this amazing discussion
ran cafe best slice of life anime before
we go of course I want to let you guys
know who these people are who are with
me whose faces but not pants you can see
here and it'll tell us a bit about
themselves of course all of their links
to their channels are in the description
let's start with you Briggs because the
ioio that's why I mean fair point
reasons I am a Briggs from all the anime
I make fact videos explain concepts from
anime and yeah that's about it and
between the beginning of this rant cafe
in the end Briggs just got a thousand
new subscribers so good job good
possible nobody breaks this channel has
been doing great guys be sure to check
it out he's a great dude doing well and
I'm gonna kick his ass at anime North
but that's unrelated we'll see about
that looks good yeah we'll see bro you
think he's so big with your muscles well
I got I got strategy Thank You Brendan
who you
I'm Britain from Bryn's fandoms I am not
attending anime North sadly however I
will watch all your vlogs and video so
please post them all but if you want to
watch some videos that I do I did a skit
very recently that I had a lot of fun
doing and if you liked it please let me
know by giving some stuff because
there's a lot of work but it's a lot of
fun so if you like those kind of videos
that's what you can see on my channel
I'm yep at brains fandoms yeah it was
hilarious
Brendon I should all try on those and
waifu's so a lot of our favorite topic
especially on the discord you guys know
so be sure to check that out and I think
a young man named anime uproar have the
funniest comment by far in that video
but you can judge boy struggle young man
distinction Tony tried to speak try to
speak let's try to hear Tony what what
don't need to you who tell up you are
what you do why are you too big you
don't even care too big
honey I need a clothes I'm all I'm a
humble man I like working with smaller
youtubers that's what I do I'm
Christopher Robin um I started my new
channel called the honeypot Naha with my
best friend Pooh my girl that loves
honey we just go out but switches she
calls good evening and we we just are
cool friends now we filled a new video
called why I was involved in a shootout
I'm sorry uh definitely check it out my
channel again that's a honeypot and yeah
that does my channel
just kidding on like a link to the
channel honeypot is in the description
it is very sexually explicit as the name
suggests however you know it's good
stuff so yes good stuff Maxine it a lot
to actually he plays a pimp on the
channel so yeah plays are painful it
anyway pimple not what's up bro
I don't think I think I'm gonna have to
renew my main pimple nut that's too good
yep I just that doesn't sound good
pimple not sounds like a just pimples
and no no mmm have multiple meetings
which is it's exactly exactly
but yeah I'm Mac from Mackel nut all
right and Michael nut I don't know how
to add a introduce but make a lot of
anime related stuff like skits and also
a lot of like I guess what I like to
call anti content so basically what
every what every other you know anime
youtuber in the grandma makes like
refuse or theories videos or vlogs and
soon-to-be cosplay but it's it's just
sarcastic and not actually what it's
supposed to be at all so I mean if you
like thinking it's something and it's
not that then come to my channel it's
great and there's there's actually
there's actually a new skit dropping
hopefully this Sunday I just got like
three quarters of the clips today some
of these people are involved in it so
not you know but I have thanks I have
pretty much pretty much everything ready
it's gonna be it's gonna it's gonna be
an amine or through lated what actually
the next few things for the next few
weeks are gonna be animated or deleted
sorry fans but that's what I do and yeah
that's that's it that's it you gotta get
sponsored by anime North Mac I'm gonna
short that's good I'll try to put
something together for you by tomorrow
like eight whole seconds eight more now
whoa that's like a whole three extra
seconds then you're allowed my man
That's not me nor your will it what I'm
saying no you limit oh I thought you
said no your willy though we can do that
too but that's important but yeah thanks
rose hashtag no your willy guys but it's
lack critic guy not me black won't meet
me
we're trending on Twitter bro it's not
my fault but anyway thank you guys again
for being guests on rent Cafe de
greatest podcast of all time in history
University ANBU says not me it's not me
singing a tumbu thanks everyone in the
chat who contributed always a pleasure
always a fun time until next time we
will see you space cowboys bay